ひょっとチャミナンです良ければ反応ほしいです
ん
ハプバーしてこれず肇社長ですあの今回は僕からじゃないですご覧くださいペアンが
参加の dm なんですけどもおすすめです
来週1月18日に国激辛客様の第2ターン
国激辛カレーやきそばが発売されます今回も圧倒的な辛さに仕上がっていて
弊社の代表はぜひ始めた調査で召し上がっていただきたいと言っておりご迷惑でなけれ
ば商品を送付したいと思っております
問題はないで
でしょうか工作もいいですねぜひ宜しくお願い致します
ベアテさん
ありがとうございます何てことしてくれたんだよもう
歴史を話しましょうなんで焼きそばの母さんには歴史がありましてまず
行きから提案グっていう赤いパッケージのパンクがあるんですこれももうほんと
びっくりするぐらいかないんですけどもまぁこれがは辛さの基準となっておりますでき
からペアぐカレーとかもあったんですけどそれのもう最上級にからやつ
激辛 max end パッケージからしてダメでしょう飛んではなく辛いもうから
いいのか
得意でともうちょっと苦しいんじゃないかっていう恐ろしいカーサの選んだが出たん
ですけども
さらにその上をにのイラストが咲いたりこちらペアネック側国激辛もうハチャメチャ
ですねから去ってたっ省の美味しさがあるからちょっと思い出してもらってくれたん
ですけどかなさって多少の美味しさがあるからみんな食べちゃうとんですけども
もう何か
ぽわい本当に僕はは正直今ぬーべーバージョンが出たということでエピスマートインド
パダは world a doodle
[音楽]
ありがとうございますありがとうございますでも発売前にいただけるということは本当
に光栄なことですからもうほんとねぺアンカーンはもう色がやばい橋マハールペンさん
本当に寝湯中バーカですねありがたいこんなの魂ダンスよだってみてください
パッケージ前回は鬼みたいな奴がいたんですけども今回はインド人ですかね今回も
しっかり書いてあります泣けるほど甘味が強いので小さな
朝もやかねがねやるな方の基礎から塾にムズイくださいまあまあ今回でも
量は派が多くないんです最近ぺタマってすとか結構あの打つ量で勝負しに来たところが
あったので今回は辛さに戻ったんでまぁこの量ならいけるでしょ
湯浅すぐ食べて行きたいと思いますちゃんっ
[音楽]
これかん
th
ています
[音楽]
うわぁ
まあ理論及ばない色や場合にてキノコなって見えます
風合う焼きそば後喜劇から彼
ああ
いやさん本ぱいやなんですよ辛く眠いだけできるや者緑だったんですよ
本当に辛いの苦手な方マジでやめた方がいいですか
僕です目はお寺に入っているといきましょういただきますから無駄だもう7
もうこの蒸気が上記で汗かくんですよいつも何だろうねこれ嬉しい甘味料でも入ってる
のかなぁかやばいやばいやばいやその2
を食うのに俺はどれだけかかるんだろうかじゃ
遺体は
r
ておりますいたしますはぁ
いただければぜっやって撮ってるんだ
んだっハいただきます
えっ
えええっ
あーよります
[音楽]
パパ
あっはっは
もうん
はい
ん
あ
甘い2演説鳩山やばいやばいやばいを張ってああああ
あああああネーターさあ今ちょっと待って本当に謝れ
まじでやばいを得た際者ブルマだよ皆さん
一口食っただけこの汗ですよ
僕つとかマジでやばいやばいちょっと待ってどうしよう
ほれ食えんわえぇなんか俺わかんない前の感覚を忘れてるからかもしれないけど前追い
国激辛より花が色はずつ何もやバキッっとチーズを載せますね
なぜのかけちゃおう俺がおかしいのかななんか前より全然可愛いんだけど怖いにも買わ
せてみます
いっちゃ歌いまーすバックパックパクパクぽんずっちゃ道な
うーん
うんからいいねー笑んでこれをこらえねー
俺と全く同じことをしてねまあねつかきたらどうなるんだろうができます
うーんああああああああああああやばいまじはチーズマヨネーズ入れてもちょっと
マイルドになったんですけど俺は無理
俺も最近はちょっと辛い物を食べるようにしてるからさー多少強くなったかなと思った
けどは米中が違いますね可憐ながスパイスが効いてるのかな
ちょっとがチームリスポやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
とりあえず
9います
いいします
アーム eager
[音楽]
どうするとするこれ勢いでくるしかないん
アレンジしてもこんなきついんだから俺でも普通にクエン酸パた俺だけだろうねぇ
rar
んけどうっくります
4ん
goo
by me
はいっ
僕の限界を超えてますこれで止めさーん
と上げてくださって本当にありがとうございます
うん
[音楽]
ブーブー言っ
あっちょ